il y a encore des rebondissements dans
l'affaire d'Alain Delon les frères et
sœurs continuent de se déchirer c'est
une histoire de fou hein des photos
inédites ont été publiées aujourd'hui
iromis vous savez iromi euhomi Romi
schneeder euh qui a qui a
dit elle a dit que non iromi schneeder
donc elle a dit que je sais plus
qu'est-ce qu'elle a dit d'ailleurs il
est en danger de mort car delan est en
danger de mort parce qu'il a arrêté son
traitement elle a pas mâché ses mot
yaromi euh regardez on va en parler avec
myiam Palomba qui fait son retour ah
elle était dans les Maldives mal ah
ouais pas du tout maldiv regardez le
récap mais non pas j'ai compris que ils
ont arrêté le traitement fin août il est
urgent qu'il il aille dans cette
clinique pour reprendre le traitement je
n'ai pas peur de dire que il est danger
de mort au mois de juillet avec le
médecin son état était stable il était
très très bien donc aujourd'hui je suis
en colère parce que les enfants a mis la
vie d'alin en danger volontairement il a
eu urgent on l'amène à cette clinique
pour qu'il reprenne le traitement vital
pour lui on peut peut-être encore le
sauver alors voilà c'est les propos
d'iromi qui a l'air très inquiète Yomi
ah oui elle est très très inquiète dans
cette le micro de Miriam si jeentends
pas bien dans cette interview qu'elle a
donné ce matin dans cette interview
qu'elle a donné ce matin sur RTL elle y
va pas de main morte effectivement
malheureux elle dit qu'il est qu'il est
qu'il est en danger que ses enfants
ne s'occupe pas bien de lui que voilà
les charg elle les charge à mort et puis
puis surtout elle dit que à cause d'eux
il peut plus il prend plus son
traitement qui est vital vital pour lui
regardez elle déclare être comme vous
l'avez dit être scandalisé parce que
font actuellement les enfants d'in Deon
écoutz écoutez ce que les autres disent
ça fait partie de secret médical c'est
c'est la vie privée et moi c'est pas mon
rôle de d'étaler ça sur la place
publique d'ailleurs c'est scandaleux et
Alain qui a toujours détesté de étaler
les linges salon en public et et et elle
dit elle confie qu'il lui manque alin
Deon oui elle confie qu'il lui manque
alors elle se frotte les mains de la de
la guerre entre les enfants elle dit
même qu'elle a eu alin Delon au
téléphone au mois de novembre dernier
que bah ça n'allait pas très fort et
puis effectivement elle recharge elle
charge elle charge encore les enfants
d'Alain Delon alors écoutez ce qu'elle
dit après on va voir les des images
photos inédites d' de long dans Paris
Match puisquil fait la de Paris Match
regardez d'abord écoutez yomis al m'a
toujours manqué je pense que je lui
manque aussi évidemment c'est mon
souhaet c'était de retourner auprès de
lui et moi j'ai toujours pris soin de
lui pour que il vivent le plus longtemps
possible al me disait toujours je serai
le centenaire il avait envie de vivre et
au mois de juin il disait oh je serai un
beau centenaire mais oui al tu seras un
très plus beau onire demande voilà alors
iromis c'était la dame de compagnie d'
elle se présentait comme sa sa compagne
elle alors ils se connaissent depuis
plus de 30 ans elle se présentait comme
sa compagne et le 5 juillet dernier elle
a été virée de de la résidence de dAlain
DELO inducci par les enfants de de
d'Alain Delon qui l'accuse en fait de
l'avoir manipulé de lui avoir piqué de
l'argent de la de de de de de les avoir
coupé de leur père en en dissimulant des
des appels téléphoniques notamment et
puis voil là de l'avoir aussi laissé
pendant des heures tout seul sur un
fauteuil roulant avec une banane et une
bouteille d'eau bref de de d'avoir
manipuler d'avoir manipulé leur père et
du coup ils ont porté plainte contre
elle l'ont viré de la résidence une
plainte qui d'ailleurs en janvier là on
vient d'apprendre que elle avait été
classée sans suite alors Paris Match a
publié des photos inédites dansun l'on
regardé voilà donc voilà donc ça
sera
sortircien voilà bah là ouais merci est
très bien ça elle est pas mal mais ça
c'est des anciennes d'accord ça c'est
des anciennes oui on on aimerait ouais
voilà donc il y en a une qui qui est
récente hein bon ça c'est des anciennes
bien entendu voilà mettez bah mettez les
les les nouvelles voilà voilà c'est
voilà voilà euh en mai 2022 quel est
l'état d' qui savez tout il va très très
mal hein comme comme comme on enfin
comme on l'apprend il a de graves
problèmes cognitifs he c'est d'ailleurs
ce qui pose problème à Anthony et Alain
et Alain Fabien parce qu'ils accusent
Anouchka de Laur avoir dissimulé cet
état Alain Fabien raconte même dans dans
une interview qui qu'il donne dans Paris
Match que son père n'a plus sa tête
qu'il est extrêmement déprimé qu'il a
envie d'en finir et que et que il pense
même au suicide et il y a même aussi des
rumeurs hein qui disent que que Alain
Delon serait même en face terminale de
cancer ouis et alors euh chérie euham il
tout le monde porte plainte contre tout
le monde est-ce qu'on peut faire un
point pour no téléspectateur parce que
je comprends plus rien alors oui
effectivement tout le monde porte
plainte contre tout le monde alors
d'abord il y a les enfants d'Alain Delon
qui ont porté pleain contre iromi au
mois de juillet comme je vous l'ai dit
les tris ça les trois les trois à ce
moment-là on les croit on les croit
hyper unis contre la dame de compagnie
bon la plainte est classée sans suite et
puis Anthony Delon décide de faire une
main courante parce qu'il accuse sa sœur
de leur avoir caché que leur père avait
fait cinq tests cognitifs en Suisse et
que ces tests cognitifs a fait révéler
que effectivement Alain Delon n'avait
plus toute sa tête donc il dépose une
main courante le 7 décembre suivi
ensuite d'une plainte d'Alain Fabien de
long qui lui porte plainte contre
Anouchka en l'accusant d'abus de
faiblesse et il en profite aussi pour
porter plainte contre les gardes du
corps d'Alain Delon qui l' accuse d'être
à la Solle de sa sœur et de de de de
d'espionner d'être là pour espionner
Alain Fabien et Anthony Delon donc voilà
on a on a une énorme on a chacun qui
porte plainte les uns contre les autres
entre-temps il y a Anouka également qui
porte plainte contre leur contre ses
frères pour diffamation harcèlement et
menace et là-dessus s'ajoute des
signalements de part et d'autres fait au
parquet de Paris et là on vient
d'apprendre ce soir que le procureur de
Montargis vient de vient de communiquer
par voie de presse et de dire que un
médecin habilité allait se rendre chez
Alain Delon pour savoir quel était son
état physique et mental et s'il fallait
le le placer sous protection judiciaire
oui ch ce sera un juge des des
contentieux de la protection qui se
prononcera mais il lui faut une
certification médicale et à ce moment-là
il verra quel est l'état d'Alain Delon
il pourra dire il faut absolument qu'il
reprenne le traitement en Suisse comme
le préconisent les avocats d'Alain Delon
et d'Anouchka il pourra dire euh ça a
été terrible le fait d'arrêter le
traitement il pourra dire il faut le
mettre sous tutelle sous curatelle ou il
est encore autonome il peut encore
décider de son propre avenir voilà là
c'est vraiment on est au niveau de
l'expertise judiciaire maintenant alors
en fait on a deux points de vue qui
s'opposent chez les enfants d'Alain
Delon d' à côté on a
Anouchka qui rêve de mettre son fils
dans une son père pardon dans une
clinique up en Suisse et donc de le
laisser croupir là pour finir sa vie et
puis de l'autre côté vous avez Anthony
alin Fabien qui veulent plus de
traitement qui veulent juste des soins
palliatifs et qui sont accusés par
Anouka d'avoir arrêté le traitement et
de lui donné juste des jus de fruits euh
qui ont été des jus de fruits voilà qui
ont été voilà prescrits par par une
naturopathe et d'ailleurs Anouchka
accuse Alain Fabien d'être très proche
d'être de cette naturopathe et de l'avir
manipuler voilà pour que pour arrêter le
traitement de son père en fait Anouchka
elle dit en clair voilà ils veulent
qu'il Meur qu'il Meur très vite alors
que alors que quoi alors
que alors que les fils alors que les
fils eux euh disent bah en fait elle
veut elle veut interner un autre père
alors que lui son rêve c'est de finir sa
vie à duci duci exactement oui qu'est-ce
qu'il veut oui il ils estiment même euh
les avocats d'Alain Delon et d'anouta
estiment même que la relation possible
entre Alain Fabien et ce médecin
nécessiterait des investigations
judiciaires de la part du procureur donc
ça va très loin ça pourrait vouloir dire
ça pourrait vouloir dire que ce médecin
a influencé pour des intérêts autres que
celui d'Alain Delon tout le protocole
médical sousentend fait que cette
naturopate une histoire d'amour avec
Alain Fabien absolument ah d'accord très
bien merci en tout cas de qu'elle aurait
violé le secret médical en transmettant
le dossier à Anthony donc voilà allez on
va suivre tout ça merci Miriam tu nous
referas un point demain si si besoin on
sera en direct bien entendu demain